well let's bring you the latest on one
of the developing stories today and that
is the future of Nicholas sturgeon and
the SNP she was of course questioned by
police over the weekend some questions
about whether or not she'll stay at the
party or whether she will be suspended
with her in the last few minutes that
the SNP are saying that she will not be
suspended let's talk just guys Connor
Gillis who joins us now from Hamilton
where Scottish labor is out campaigning
uh Connor she's staying for the time
being it seems
yeah s p headquarters confirming what
Humsa use of the first minister of
Scotland has revealed in the last few
minutes during a visit to Inverness in
the north of the country that Nicola
sturgeon the longest serving first
minister of Scotland the woman who was
in charge here for more than 3 000 days
will not be suspended from the Scottish
national party the party that she led
for such a long period of time and this
comes amid mounting pressure amid
growing calls from many within the SMP
over the course of today that she should
at least decide and take it upon herself
to step back from the SNP amid this
police investigation she became the
third and the most high profile arrest
in this investigation dating back to
2021 examining the finances and the
fundraising of the SMP yesterday she was
detained for a period of more than seven
hours and faced a number of questions
from those detectives around the funding
and the finances of the SMP let's
remember her husband the one-time
long-standing chief executive of the SNP
Peter model was arrested a number of
months ago he too was released without
charge pending further inquiries but
there has been concern over the course
of the last couple of hours notably from
one of the former leadership candidates
Ash Regan who stood against humza Yusuf
to replace Nicholas sturgeon she said
that Nicola sturgeon should be
considering her position while this
investigation continues Angus Brendan
McNeil the smpmp for The Western Isles
he too has suggested a similar course of
action because Nicholas sturgeon had a
different approach when she was in
charge of of the Scottish national party
there were a number of politicians who
faced uh questions from police in recent
years and her approach during that
particular moment of issue for the party
was to request and to ask those members
of the party to relinquish their
membership while the police conducted
their inquiries so there has been a
suggestion of double standards why are
we here in rutherglen well this is where
Scottish labor is looking to capitalize
on the political misfortunes of the SNP
over the course of the last couple of
months there could be a looming
by-election here the one-time smpmp
Margaret Ferrier who traveled to
Westminster and traveled various places
here in central Scotland while she had
coronavirus and was subsequently found
guilty of that well there could be a
by-election looming to replace her soap
labor are hoping to capitalize on that
and they have been out and about today
and I think we can hear what Scottish
labor leader arasarawar has been saying
in the last few minutes